hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Game of Thrones episode 3 QA just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet there were a couple really
adorable theories that people were
asking about based on some of the stuff
we've seen like the Hodor theory or the
new Mad King brand theory so I made sure
to add those to this let's start with
the Mad King one first so here we go
black Louis what if bran realized people
from time travelers can hear him he
starts talking to the Mad King and
that's what makes him mad because he
hears some strange voices and whispers
that there's a totally amazing theory I
totally love it but I don't think it's
gonna happen it seems like the more
brand flashbacks we get the more brand
tries to do so there might be a moment
where he actually does try to change the
past that reaction from Ned Stark in the
past made it seem like he heard bran and
we know there's that scene in the
trailer where bran is seeing the night's
king it almost looks like he grabs him
they might have cut that in a really
misleading way but I think that's what
all these scenes where he's trying to
speak to people are building towards
where the night's he actually does grab
him so it's like yes things can be
affected in the past but I think it's
all set up building to that night's King
moment they do a pretty good job of
setting things up in previous episodes
and paying them off later like all the
are plus L equals J stuff or are you
getting whacked when she says she has
four brothers then corrects it to three
brothers so hopefully they don't wait
too long before paying that off because
we actually haven't even seen the White
Walkers yet this season episode four
next week is supposed to be a couple
minutes longer than a normal episode so
there might be an extra long WTF
post-credit white walker scene let's do
the Hodor one next so plop Nos just
wondering what's your view on the
theories of Hodor Willis working into
Liana's horse and then the horse being
killed so the adorable is like the most
adorable theory ever I don't think it's
true but I really like it it's rooted in
the idea that maybe Hodor was a war or
Willis however you want to think about
him in the past and he lost his mind
because of an accident and lyanna
stark's horse might be named Hodor so
the reason he can only say Hodor is
because he still thinks he's a horse
because he worked for too long there was
an accident
and so his mind was affected but I do
believe that they're going to pay off
that Hodor flashback like he can talk
what happened I think it'd be
disingenuous for them to give us that
scene and not pay it off this season so
the part about this that I do buy into
is that he made some sacrifice in the
past
and was injured like some sacrifice to
help House Stark but I don't believe the
Lyanna Stark horse part that's the
adorable part just the idea that Hodor
thinks that he's a horse so he just
walks around saying his name horses are
very intelligent creatures so they would
actually probably be like Hodor is on
the TV show so I mean it's not outside
the realm of possibilities but I think
it just sounds too adorably ridiculous
for it to be true next question Johnny
Neil asks in the show the three-eyed
Raven said he's a thousand years old
can't be the Bloodraven yes the the
timeline was a little wonky the
Bloodraven isn't that old he's one of
the oldest people alive in Westeros but
he's nowhere near a thousand years old
the Bloodraven is someone left over from
the time of the Blackfyre rebellion
he's a Targaryen bastard one of the
bastards of the Targaryen King at the
time so he's closer to being over 200
years old in the books the three-eyed
Raven is the Bloodraven so I think what
the TV show has done is had a few
liberties with that or when he was
talking about being a thousand years old
he was just talking about traveling back
in history a thousand years so he's seen
a thousand years of history even if he's
not chronologically a thousand years old
but be prepared for a compression of
timeline with respect to the long night
so the long night in the books is
something from 8,000 years ago when he
says a thousand years he might be
talking about the long night of the TV
show so that might be where that
thousand years came from
next question rugosa to Bess I don't
believe that shaggy-dog is dead I can't
see the umbers going to join the
Bolton's I think they're creating a ruse
I think that's what you meant to say to
stab the Bolton's in the back so yeah
what you're talking about is a
conspiracy theory like Grand Northern
conspiracy there are a lot of people
that think that that wasn't shaggy dog
walking away from that my initial
takeaway was just what you see is what
you get great John number loyal to the
Starks [ __ ] rich douchebag son
inherits his father's Kingdom in decides
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about anything
that his father cared about so my
takeaway was just that small John number
is a total dick and he only cares about
himself but the other thing that people
were pointing to is that the the head
looked way smaller than a normal
direwolf said people were like that
can't be big enough to be a direwolf
said that looks like a regular wolf said
until I see some more compelling
evidence from the TV show I'm just gonna
assume that there's no umber conspiracy
they're just going to be dicks on the TV
show but that's not really the way they
come across in the book
so that's one of the book changes I
think they made it the TV show next
question miss Buckner desk
do you believe that Arya will ever
reunite with John well I definitely
think that she's gonna be back in
Westeros I don't know how long that's
gonna be
hopefully it'll happen sometime before
the end of this season but I wouldn't be
surprised if they kept pushing that away
you have to remember that even if Arya
stays training with the faceless men and
going on missions in the east as a
faceless man her missions would take her
all over the world so at one point or
another she would make her way back to
Westeros I think there'll be at least
one stark left even after the war for
the dawn so the other thing that also
kind of makes me feel like she will see
John at some other point was the list
like the list will take her back to
King's Landing at some point and then
eventually George our Martin said in the
books just to pull in some some book
stuff that the characters will slowly
start to converge as we move towards the
end of the story
like Martin says at the beginning of the
story everyone starts out together then
they slowly get spread to the four winds
their stories take them in different
directions then at a certain point as
the story reaches its climax they all
start to converge again these things
move towards the ending next question
magical being asks just a random thought
what if the whole you'll never walk
again brand but you will fly thing means
he's literally going to fly like on a
dragon well the three-eyed Raven did say
that he would leave the cave and he made
it sound like it would be physical like
you won't be stuck in this cave like
I've been the TV show has been playing a
little fast and loose with bran
storyline in the books it definitely
seems like bran is going to replace the
three-eyed Raven the last screen seer
inside that weird wood like he's going
to be integrated with the root system
just like the three-eyed Raven is but I
guess the TV show just feels like it's
more exciting visually if bran is out
walking around seeing things so yes it's
totally possible that bran could ride
one of the Dragons but usually the
question when people are talking about
bran and Dragons is could brand warg a
dragon and George are Martin's only
answer for this he gets asked to all the
time and he only says there's no
precedent for it so he's not saying it's
not possible he's just kind of saying
that he hasn't really figured that out
or decided that he wants to make that a
thing next question Sebastian says that
Arthur Dayne fight seemed was [ __ ]
awesome yeah a lot of people are
wondering if that's their way of
apologizing for sand snakes lack of
fighting last season there were
definitely a lot of people that were
upset because the sand snakes are
supposed to be some of the most badass
fighters in the world and they felt like
season
five fight scenes were lackluster so I
think it's totally possible that like
when they were going into season six
they wanted to show Arthur Dayne who's
supposed to be the actual best the one
fighter that everyone believed was the
best to be so badass that they're like
okay we're gonna have him dual wield
we're gonna show a version of dawn which
I actually I do think that this is dawn
on second look it seems like they just
changed it dramatically for the TV show
the first time I watched the episode the
reason I didn't think this was dawn is
because it wasn't glowing and he was
dual wielding and it's implied that Dawn
is not I mean it's not quite as big as
ice but it's a giant sword you would
have to to hand wield it but this is
definitely my new favorite fight on the
TV show next to Oberyn Martell vs. the
mountain the only way I think they could
top this is if they have Arya do like
some crazy water dancing scene if she
becomes this crazy Syrio Forel level
fighter because the water dancers
actually do exist in Braavos but they're
like a completely separate organization
from the faceless men next question
black screen s brain wasn't allowed to
get up in the tower because his last
tower experience ended not so well yeah
getting pushed out by Jaime Lannister no
I seriously think that we're gonna see
the rest of that even if it's done in a
roundabout way like Ned Stark walking
out with a baby or something like that
like I said with the Hodor think they
might not want to answer it right away
because there's some super spoilery
explanation or it's part of some big
twist in the plot but they would be
trolling so hard you know it'd be such a
middle finger to not finish paying off
that moment the thing about the
three-eyed Ravens reaction is he looks
like a parent who's trying to keep his
child from seeing something really
horrible or shocking so my takeaway from
that is that he's just not ready for
bran to learn that Jon Snow isn't the
brother that he thinks he is but he did
say the brand needs to learn everything
so I think that implies that they're
gonna pay that off before the end of the
season next question Chris asks do you
think that arias kill list and the
insinuation of trial by combat was
brought up in this episode to imply that
cleganebowl might actually be a thing
later this season or next yeah I mean it
remains to be seen how fast they move
along but yeah definitely clean bold
they're definitely hinting at that but
that involves a big twist that hasn't
been revealed yet without getting into
super spoilers yes I do think that
cleganebowl is possible but there are a
couple hoops that you have to jump
through to get there a character has to
come back and then the faith has to
choose him as
their champion when Cersei chooses
zombie mountain is his champion so the
high Sparrow would have to have his own
little birds telling him that said
character was waiting in the wings just
to make as many puns as possible to come
back and fight when needed
next question raw power asks was Ned
using ice at the Tower of joy seen the
sword that landed on the ground looked
different yeah I don't think that that
was ice it's a two-handed great sword so
it'd be enormous we might get to see
more of Robert's rebellion during bran
flashbacks in this season or future
seasons but I think the idea is that the
bastard sword that he's using here is
just more versatile like if he's gonna
be fighting in close combat it's a more
effective weapon than using the great
sword like that would be a lot more
useful if he didn't have to fight a
bunch of people at the same time so
Arthur Dayne actually probably has the
right idea here dual wielding thank you
everyone for so many questions these are
always a ton of fun to do like I said I
think they're gonna continue to keep
paying off things and bran flashbacks it
just remains to be seen how much they
drag them out maybe to the last episode
maybe not it would kind of suck if they
waited to the very last episode to pay
off that Jon Snow tower of joy scene but
definitely prepare for that I think they
plotted the flashbacks in a way that
they explain things but that makes you
want to watch every single episode so
there's a little bit of TV trickery in
this in that they want you to tune in
next week to get the answer a giveaway
time congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner kenneth XD you win a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
that's just on the about page so I'll
start a new round whenever I post my
next game of Thrones video if there are
any special bonus videos that you guys
want this week just let me know in the
comments while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about the prophecy the prince
who has promised R + L equals J like a
little bit better explainer at the Tower
of joy stuff and you can click here for
my episode 3 video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you